the winter of industrial action looms
now a date is set for the biggest nurses
strike in a hundred years you can repair
a leak or you can repair the whole roof
and we've the government's waited until
the whole route's going to go and that's
that's what's going to happen if they
don't invest now nurses like Mark walk
out for two days in December I'm at the
top of band five I I get with blood I
get a bit of extra for living in London
but my take home is basically 30 000 a
year plus that it's not enough for the
the stress the pressure we're under we
have people's lives in our hands we're
University trained we have a massive
amount of skills and knowledge and the
pay doesn't match that we're regularly
full by midday now we have all our beds
full all our waiting space is full and
there's still people queuing out the
door and we have to see them we have to
provide care and we're trying our best
but the stress is immense there are
strong feelings on both sides and some
like Naomi voted against strike action
cancer doesn't hold still for strike
action it still progresses is and a lot
of these people need urgent treatment
and the whole purpose of a strike action
is to make an impact it doesn't to me
seem like it's in the interest of
patients and I think if anything is
going to put fear amongst the general
public which is unnecessary and again it
goes against the core values of being a
nurse
a record seven million people already on
waiting lists in England the union
insists patients safety won't be
compromised
but as a new prime minister tries to
grip a row of a public sector pay his
message there isn't enough money I have
enormous respect and gratitude on us as
everyone does for the incredible job
they do and I know things are difficult
right now for everyone because of what's
happening with inflation and that's why
our plans that we outlined last week
will get a group of inflation and bring
it down that's really important and in
the meantime what what the unions are
asking for I think is a 19 pay rise and
I think most people watching will will
recognize that that's obviously
unaffordable it's possible strikes could
be staggered whatever happens industrial
action will compound the NHS backlog
it's hard to see a deal being reached
the two sides are miles apart and where
the Tories ordinarily wouldn't shy away
from a fight with the unions and we know
that they have directed more money
towards the NHS in the Autumn statement
around nurses pay is uncomfortable for a
government that wants to be seen to be
on the side of the NHS
it's a moment of political danger for
the PM Mark says nurses have limited
leverage and it's not a decision anyone
is taking lightly Ali fortsku Sky News